ccsd welcome back another wave of
students under the hybrid learning plan
today those in grades 6
9 and 12 return to face-to-face
instruction this morning
good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us for this special edition of 8
news now at 3
i'm kirsten joyce christian is on
assignment and he'll be joining us in
just a few minutes time
now as more students and staff go back
inside school buildings discussions are
starting around the direction of
education for the upcoming school year
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the concerns and suggestions to
possibly improve the district
superintendent dr jesus draw seeks
feedback from the community about the
future of education in the clark county
school district
he's on a listening tour and his first
stop was here in henderson
what do we need to do differently better
when we come back
august and beyond dr jarrah asking
questions for families to consider
do you think high school kids should
come to school five days a week
highlighting possible learning options
while visiting the city of henderson
multi-generational center
he along with trustee lisa guzman and
the deputy superintendent
welcome an open discussion about what's
happening in the district
that's why i was here today get my voice
heard for my kids my neighbors kids and
all kids really
jacqueline wicker is a mother of three
elementary age students
she wants in-person learning five days a
week and
less chromebooks i think getting them
off the computers
all the time is i don't want to keep
that
ccsd plans to give families a choice of
distance education
or in-person instruction in the future
but
this session allows parents to possibly
influence
the district's eventual direction we're
in a really good place
where we are today and i think we'll be
in a better place
among us the listening tour continues
this evening with a virtual session
at 5 30 on the ccsd facebook page
reporting in henderson kristin drummond
8 news now